So much undergrads, really nice
to be here for the full reunion.
And welcome everyone, at least virtually.
I hope I get to see you in
person at the next one.
I'm delighted to be able to talk to
you today about what's happening in
the FinTech payment space.
There's kind of a revolution going
on as most of you probably know.
And I want to get your feedback as well.
So I'm going to leave a healthy amount
of time at the end for you to comment or
add questions, or give me your
thoughts on where this space is going.
It's actually very timely for me because
I'm going to be talking to the GSB Trust
in the next couple of weeks about the same
topic and I'm sure that you could give me
some hints about the sorts of
questions that they'll ask.
I've been working on in this area for
the past years,
both on research and policy work.
And this year, it seems to be all
consuming in terms of the policy work.
I've been doing some work on stable coins,
on Central Bank digital currencies,
and on China's Central Bank
digital currency.
And I can talk about that project work but
I want to jump into
the substance of the topic.
And maybe give everyone a sense of why
we're actually discussing this and
what's wrong with the current
payment system, why is everybody so
excited about upgrading it.
For those of you that
are working in FinTech,
you probably know that the protagonists
in this story are always Alice and Bob.
I think that goes back quite a few
years from the computer science
literature in cryptocurrencies.
Alice, in this situation, wants to pay
Bob, the baker, $8 for a loaf of bread.
And the question is,
how is she going to pay Bob?
Now today I'm going to be talking
about general purpose payments and
not as much about the wholesale
interbank payment system,
and how that's also going
through a significant upgrade,
particularly in security settlement and
cross border payments.
But if you have questions in those areas,
let's discuss that because actually I'm
quite passionate about improvements
that are happening in that area as well.
I mean, for example,
the treasury market last year,
could have used a substantial upgrade in
its payments and settlement system, and
instead we got a very significant
problem in that market.
But again, today we're going to
focus on Alice and Bob.
And most of you know that in
most of the world to Alice
would typically hand over paper,
money or more frequently a credit card.
The credit card could be in her
mobile phone wallet overlay,
but it's still typically
a credit card based payment.
And it would eventually flow
through the bank payment rails,
like almost all payments
in the current system.
So Alice will send a message
using her credit card or
a mobile phone app, a tap,
a swish or whatever.
And her bank will take
$8 out of her account,
send it through the bank payment rails,
which is pretty complicated, actually.
And it'll get to Bob's bank in a day or
two, maybe three.
But Bob instantly gets a message
saying the money is coming, so
you can give Alice the loaf of bread.
That experience is working pretty
well these days for Alice, but
she doesn't really know what's going
on in the guts of the bank payment
rails that's costing Bob so
much to take that payment, and
it's causing many other costs and
delays that I want to talk about.
So these payment rails
are illustrated in this schematic.
So Alice could be
customer one of bank one.
She's the blue dot at the top left.
Her bank is bank one, b1.
And Bob's bank is the green dot, b3, and
he's maybe customer seven of bank three,
and the payment is a deduction
from Alice's account at bank one.
And then bank one will credit probably
bank three through the central
bank payment system,
which in the United States is Fedwire.
And it can also go through
a private payment system and
be merged and then flow through Fedwire.
As I said,
this tends to take a long time, and
along these payment rails there
are various fees being extracted.
If it's a credit card payment,
the interchange fees that Bob has to pay
are actually quite severe
in the United States.
I want to illustrate that in this diagram,
which comes from the McKinsey Global
Payments Report from last year.
That's a bit of a complicated diagram.
I'm not going to go through
every element of it.
But I want you to focus on the left stack.
That's the North American payments stack.
I got the data from this report and
we compiled it so that it's easier to see.
And you can see that the payments
stack for US, the US payment system or
the North American payment system,
including Canada, is heavily on
the consumer side, meaning consumers
are paying a lot in the United States
relative to the rest of the world and
particularly a lot for credit cards.
So, the interchange fee for the US is,
depending on what card you have,
it's $2 to 250 per 100, which is huge,
actually, relative to the actual cost.
Europe regulates interchange fees for
cards, and it's much smaller.
It's about 10% of
the payment stack in Europe.
Well, it's on average 15% for
the rest of the world.
Not only is the US payments stack heavily
weighted towards consumer payments,
meaning the profit margins are bigger
on the general retail side,
it's also just bigger in total dollars.
So, you can see from the legend at
the top that US payment revenues,
and that's basically profits gross
of overhead and other expenses,
constitute about 2.3% of US GDP,
that's huge.
Probably many of you didn't know if you're
not a payments expert, that it costs so
much to run the US payments system.
By the way,
paper cash also costs an enormous amount.
And that's not counted in this diagram.
Paper cash is also a pretty
costly thing to do.
The rest of the world, well, let's say
take Europe, Middle East, and Africa,
that's 1.7%.
So the US payment system
is a lot more expensive.
And it's not really because
it's that much better.
It's because there are relatively
high profit margins.
So many have been calling for
an improvement.
And that's gotten off to a head start
this year because of China's big news,
its central bank digital currency and
the fact that China has
already had extremely,
efficient mobile payment systems
run by the two large FinTech firms,
Ant Group and Tencent.
And Americans have been kind of
commenters, at least have been needling,
the Fed and Congress and
the administration saying, gosh,
if China can do this,
why can't the United States do this?
And it's,
it's gotten into a bit of a space race.
But let's go to more on the fundamentals
and talk about Financial inclusion,
and I've taken these numbers from
the World Bank's Global Findex Database.
And I plotted on the vertical axis
financial inclusion as percent of
households that actually have
access to the payment system,
whether through digital means or
otherwise through banks.
And you can see that in high income
economies it's typically over 90%,
in developing economies more like 60-ish%.
China is quite high, India is quite high,
Kenya is quite high.
Those economies, China, India, and
Kenya, have had the benefit of very
effective mobile payment systems relative
to the rest of the developing economy.
And China's numbers, if you updated this
chart to today it's actually much better.
Moreover, the digital payment system
in China is very advanced because of
Alipay and WeChat Pay, the two private
services that I mentioned a moment ago.
So for example, if you're in a city in
China, 95% of payments are being made,
of digital payments which are most of
them, are being made by one of those two
services, so they have a virtual
duopoly on digital payments in China.
One of the big pushes in
the United States, in Congress and
in the administration,
is to change the US payment system so
as to increase financial inclusion.
There are about 5 to 7 million households
in the United States that
don't have access to banking.
And about twice that many that
are relatively weakly banked,
meaning they have very costly or
inefficient access to the banking system.
So they're using special expensive
paycheck cashing services,
and remittance services that
are extremely expensive,
and the United States wants
to do something about that.
At the same time the United States
is dealing with the advent of
cryptocurrencies, as you well know.
And just recently the president's working
group is developing a report on what to
do about stablecoins, which is the type of
cryptocurrency that's commonly used for
making payments, I'm going to
get to those in just a minute.
So we're basically on the edge of a major
change in direction in the United States,
and I'm going to talk about
the options at the end.
But let me just mention briefly the one
option is to improve the existing
bank payment rails,
make them more efficient, faster, cheaper,
more widely available and accessible to
the under-banked part of the population.
Another approach is to let
FinTech payment services,
including stablecoins,
compete with banks to make payments.
And then, a third option is to introduce
a US central bank digital currency.
Now, all of those have a myriad of
design choices or there's a big menu for
each of those, and
we won't get into all of it today but
I want to engage upon
some of those issues.
If you look at Vietnam,
that's a country that's ripe for
leapfrogging all of these issues,
like Kenya did, with fast,
efficient mobile phone based payments, so
I expect Vietnam to happen very quickly.
India has the benefit of UPI and Aadhaar,
which in combination have made bank
rail payments extremely accessible,
cheap, fast, and easy to use in India.
Although that comes with the need for
everyone to identify themselves,
and sometimes Americans
don't like to be putting their
identities into a large data set.
What about cross-border payments,
well I'm not going to talk
about that at length today.
But if Alice, who is customer one
at bank one needs to pay Bob in
another country, let's say Canada,
or Argentina, or
some other country, then Alice's
bank needs to find a bank that
has correspondent banking
relationships in Bob's country.
That would be bank three finding bank
four, times those food chains of finding
a correspondent banking relationship
extend to three or four along the chain.
And every bank along that chain needs to
check the modality of the payment and
of course needs to check,
Well, to make sure that it gets paid for
the payment as well.
So it's a very, very expensive and
annoyingly slow,
and I'm sure you've all dealt with
that when you've tried to make
a cross-border payment or
a remittance payment.
If we go the bank railed route, we could
do what's called a fast payment system.
So the key defining properties of that
are that it's available 24-7-365,
you have near real-time access to
the funds by the recipient of the payment.
And there are various design approaches.
You can either do it where the payment
is honored immediately but
the banks settle it up
later among themselves, and
they merge their payments with each other,
that's called deferred net settlement.
Or you can have straight through
real time gross settlement,
which seems to be the way that most
fast payment systems are going.
The United States is doing one of those
right now, the Fed is introducing FedNow,
which will speed up the bank rail
payments and make them more accessible.
Although, if you want to
get a payment service,
you still need to go to
a bank to get that service.
And one of the reasons I believe
that the US banking system is so
inefficient at payments is
that banks don't really have
an incentive to make it so
easy to move your money and so
cheap that they will discourage
you from using their services,
in a Walled Garden sense, and
of course pay their fees and
keep your money on deposit in their banks.
And as you may or may not know that US
bank deposit rates are extremely low
relative to wholesale rates.
That's a not very well understood point,
that US bank deposits are very
non-competitive in terms
of paying you what they're getting for
their money.
So simply doing a fast payment system
like FedNow is a big step forward,
but in my view it needs to be
coupled by something that causes
the banks to compete harder to
offer payments more competitively.
So here are some examples
of fast payment systems.
Korea was really one of
the first countries to do this.
Bank of Mexico has SPEI,
which is very successful.
Sweden has a private system.
United Kingdom has introduced
a nonprofit utility.
Singapore has fast payments,
including cross border fast
payments that it's introducing.
The European Central Bank has its
TARGET Instant Payment system or TIPS.
And as I mentioned,
the US is coming online with FedNow,
probably in the next year and
a half to two years.
So that's one approach.
Another approach,
as I mentioned, is stablecoins.
And you can think Libra, but
now it's changed its name to Diem and
it's been reorganized.
Or you can think of coin bases,
stable coin, which is called USDC.
These are the two largest stable coins.
Well, Tether is the largest but
it's not as stable as,
I don't include it as really stable,
although its price stays near $1.
The assets backing
Tether are very sketchy.
But here's how Alice would get her
stable coins to make payments in
the United States.
She would go to her issuer,
which could be her bank, or
it could be the Facebook which will
provide it through its issuer of DM.
Or it could be at coin-based,
you'll get online and
load your wallet with USDC.
And so in this case the issuer was taking
$500 in regular money from Alice and
giving her 500 stable coins tokens.
The issuer gives $500 to the trust that
owns the assets backing the stable coin,
assuming there are assets backing it.
And then the asset invests that
money in the backing assets,
which can be bank deposits, they can
be treasury bills, commercial paper.
In the case of Tether, the backing
assets were basically a black box until
there was litigation in New York state
that forced them to disclose that it's
mostly commercial paper and not as safe
perhaps as US authorities might prefer.
The trust will then use those
assets to authorize the issuer
to give the tokens to Alice.
Now she can go out and
send them anywhere, using a mobile app or
Internet online, and
make payments, or do peer to peer,
pay for a cup of coffee,
whatever she wants.
Now the authorities in the United States
are quite concerned on a number of
grounds.
First, will the assets backing
these tokens be solid?
Second, will all of the money coming
out of the banks cause a problem for
the banks not having enough deposits.
I'm actually not worried about that one.
Another issue is, will the blockchain on
which the tokens are issued be stable,
operationally stable and up 24/7 365?
If a lot of Americans start
depending on stable coins,
the authorities are worried about that.
So those are on the worry side.
On the positive side, the advent of
stable coins may provide a lot of new
opportunities to make new kinds of
payments, like doing Internet of things,
smart contracting, programmable payments.
And they may also cause
more competition for banks,
which I think would be a very good thing.
The other element of the payment
revolution that's going on globally is
central bank digital currencies or CBDCs.
And in this case, Alice and Bob simply
could have an account at the central bank.
They would have an account at
the central bank in effect, and
Alice's message to pay Bob would
simply mean the dollars moves out of
Alice's account at the central bank and
into Bob's account.
So that's very quick and easy.
It would be super cheap.
It would in principle be available
to anyone anywhere on a simple
mobile phone app or
on the Internet by any other device and
make payments quite simple,
although there are some downsides.
First of all, maybe you don't want the
central bank having to look after every
single account in the United States, and
the Fed might be worried about that.
Secondly, the central bank is going to
have to check on the legality of all
these payments.
That's a big operation.
Moreover, in order to do that, central
bank needs to keep tabs on everyone and
that's a potential concern for
those worried about privacy.
So this trade off between privacy and
legal payments is
causing a lot of concern in terms
of the design side of this.
And I won't go into any details but
I hope you'll ask me about that later.
I'll take one of the central banks
that's investigating this and
just discuss what they
view as the benefits of or
objectives of exploring central
bank digital currencies.
So, one is making sure that
you're not relying on a flaky or
sketchy payment provider,
so resilient payments.
I'll skip to three, supporting
competition, efficiency, and innovation.
Meeting future payment needs,
improving the availability and
usability of central bank money,
addressing the consequences of the decline
in paper cash which is an issue.
What do you do once there's
no more paper money?
I went to Sweden recently and
they wouldn't take my paper
Swedish Krona to pay my hotel bill.
And then provide a better method for
making cross border payments, better,
faster, cheaper.
When we do see central bank
digital currencies in practice,
they're mostly going to be done this way,
the way that China is doing it.
So when Alice gets her central
bank digital currency in China
which is going to be called
eCNY that means electronic CNY,
CNY is the foreign exchange symbol for
Chinese renminbi.
Alice will get it from a bank,
most likely her payment service provider,
and she'll send a message to her
bank to tell the central bank to
deduct 80 renminbi from her account,
put it in Bob's account.
Bob will get a message from his payment
service provider that the money has been
paid, and he'll give Alice the bread, and
that'll all happen in a second or two.
And by the way, China's CBDC is
not done as a cryptocurrency or
on a blockchain,
it's a central database management system.
And they're doing that in order to
get sufficient speed throughput of
about 300,000 transactions a second.
Although I think that cryptocurrency
experts will figure out how to do
with that fast pretty soon.
Now China doing this on its own,
as I mentioned, banks are helping,
also telephone companies,
providing the apps and
software, and FinTech payment service
providers, the traditional ones in China,
WeChat Pay and Alipay, and
many others in the private sector.
And this is a likely public partnerships
in the United States as well,
although in the US it's still
only at the research stage.
The MIT and
the Federal Reserve Bank of Boston
are collaborating on research led by Dr.
Neha Narula at MIT.
But for now, it's just research,
there's no development.
Many other countries though, are
developing central bank due to currencies.
You can see in this chart from the Bank
for International Settlements, significant
increase in the last few years in the
number of central banks working on CBDCs.
Some of them are only doing wholesale,
some are doing general purpose,
most are doing both.
And most of them are still
in the stage of experiments,
research, proof of concept, and
only a few are in development.
As I mentioned, most cases, you're
going to have this hybrid system where
Alice doesn't deal directly
with the central bank,
she deals directly with her
payment service provider.
And you need to make sure that
the app that Alice gets for
her phone is completely interoperable
with the app that Bob is using, and
that means very strong standard setting.
So the design implications,
they take time to develop,
and privacy The privacy side
of it securing the data
securing the resiliency of the system
operationally against outages and
also something to check on anti money
laundering and other illegal payments.
All of that needs to be designed
in a place like the United States.
Here are some major CBDC developers.
And as I mentioned,
China has already done it.
Officially the release comes next year,
but there are already hundreds of millions
of people well, over 100 million
people in China have used it.
And for a large volume of payments,
Sweden has been doing this for
development work for some time.
Korea, Nigeria, Bank of Canada,
I'm a Canadian, by the way,
Canada has said,
we're going to develop it now.
But we're not going to release it until
we feel that it's really necessary,
and really necessary means maybe paper
money will not be any longer acceptable or
maybe a private cryptocurrency that
we don't want to have in our payment
system is getting too much traction so
we'll try to hit it off with a CBDC.
I've listed some readings at the bottom.
If you want to get in touch with me at
any time and ask questions on the side or
ask for some of these readings,
let me know.
You can always reach me here
at the business school.
I'm getting close to the end
of my prepared remarks.
So I hope you're getting
ready with your questions.
I'm looking forward to your comments and
your questions.
So what are the policy options and
let's say for the United States.
By the way, one of my projects with Dr.
Elizabeth economy,
we're co-directing an expert group of 27
leading experts from national security,
economics, finance, policy,
former government officials
several former members of
the national security council.
Former undersecretaries of the treasury,
former head of a central bank,
some lot of top experts and our policy
group is attempting to provide at least,
a roadmap for
policy to the United States government.
And we're focusing in particular on
the implications of China's CBDC.
A lot of people are worried
that China may somehow take
advantage of its central bank
digital currency to get ahead
of the US in a way that the US
might need a plan to deal with.
Among the plans are simply improve
the US payment system, but also provide
a central bank digital currency that would
give the United States leading position
internationally in how central bank
digital currencies are being used.
Then at this point, there's some
disagreement among the leadership at
the Fed about whether a CBDC development
project would be a good idea or not,
with some governors of the Fed saying,
there's no need,
it's a solution in search of a problem.
And one central bank governor saying that
she can't get her head around the idea of
not developing a central
bank digital currency.
So US policy, well, one approach as I
mentioned, you could use regulation and
fast payment infrastructure to get
a more open and competitive background
payment system, something that
allows entry by Fintech firms, and
basically reduces the walled garden
effect around the banks, and
fast payments of course providing
the operational foundation.
The second approach is to allow or even
encourage compliant private stablecoins,
subject of course,
to the regulations that you would need,
including interoperability so
that people could
exchange payments even if they didn't
have exactly the correct apps.
A third approach is to encourage
not necessarily stablecoins but
other FinTech payments service providers
to enter the bank real payment systems.
And they could do that if they were to
get accounts at the Federal Reserve.
Again, it would be subject to strong
compliance and interoperability standards.
And then finally the kind of the nuclear
option because it's such a big deal and
it's so disruptive to banking and
the payment landscape
is to introduce a general purpose,
central bank digital currency.
And when I testified to
the Senate Banking Committee this summer,
I said you should develop in my view,
a central bank digital currency
now should begin developing it now
because that takes five or six years at
least before you'll have a CBDC that
you will know its costs and benefits.
And if you wait until you
think it's necessary,
it'll take you five years from that point.
But I'm hoping that option
one could be enough so
that it doesn't have to be
run by the Central Bank.
My fear, however, that a CBDC may be
necessary and as I said, I'm recommending
that United States pursue that
immediately rather than putting it off.
The Fed is about to release a white
paper that's been delayed twice now,
because I think it's still
making up its mind on whether or
at least what its stance should be.
The white paper is only going to be
a discussion of costs and benefits and
a request for comment.
But I think the Fed is genuinely uncertain
about whether it's a good idea and
it's waiting for leadership from
Congress and the administration on this.
So with that,
I want to turn it back to all of you.
I feel like I've been
running a monologue here.
I want to hear what you have to say.
I see some chats.
>> Yes,
we've had a lot of questions come in.
Can we start off by sending a little
bit of baseline knowledge for
our audience of what is
the difference between CBDCs and
general cryptocurrency,
such as Bitcoin and how Blockchain works?
>> Sure.
Well, a CBDC doesn't tell you whether
it's a cryptocurrency meaning
it's on a blockchain trades like
a tokenized money or whether it's
as a central database management
system like the one that China has.
A cryptocurrency as you know is typically
an asset which is called the currency but
in some cases like Bitcoin you
can call it a currency but
it's an extremely volatile asset.
It's only used to some
extent to make payments.
It's other uses are mostly
related to speculation.
It has the advantage that it doesn't
require a trusted third party, and
that's a very cool design,
and other cryptocurrencies,
these are permissionless cryptocurrencies,
also have this advantage that
they don't require a trusted third party,
everybody is democratically just
transferring money on the same blockchain,
which is in the cloud somewhere.
A stablecoin is a type of cryptocurrency,
whose price is intended to be constant
in terms of fiat money like one for
one and ideally, and right now stablecoins
are being used mainly as a medium of
exchange in the cryptocurrency space.
They're not yet being used much for
general payments in the US retail
markets but they could be.
So that's what I would say,
an answer to that question, but
I'm happy to take a follow up.
>> Well, related to that,
we have somebody asked,
could you comment on the valuation
approach for non-stable cryptocurrencies?
Like Bitcoin.
>> Okay, so it's a bit like gold.
In fact, Larry Summers recently said it's
the new gold in the sense that it's worth
whatever people are willing to pay for it.
Hoping that they can sell it later to
somebody else who will pay more for it.
And I think that characterizes
most cryptocurrency investments.
And they are getting very popular.
I read a report yesterday by one
of Stanford's former PhD students,
Michael Schwartz,
who's the chief economist at Microsoft.
Who feels that there's a tremendous
amount of potential growth in the total
market value of cryptocurrencies,
not only for speculation.
But because people want a place
to store money that they don't
want anyone else to know about.
So right now they're using
paper $100 bills, or
paper 500 euro notes, or
1,000 swiss franc notes.
And that's pretty cumbersome,
and it's hard to transfer those.
But it's working pretty well for the
people that want to keep their wealth in
a private forum, and
that would include a lot of criminals.
But other than storing wealth privately,
which is a bit illicit
in many cases or very illicit,
or making illegal payments.
Bitcoin and many other currencies
are used for speculative purposes.
And I think that's the majority
of the transactions are.
People hoping Bitcoin will go up and
they buy it, or
they think it might be going down so
they sell it.
It's extremely volatile.
As far as as valuing it, as I said,
if you can put a price on gold,
then you can put a price
on Bitcoin pretty well.
>> What are the implications of
all of this on money laundering?
>> Yeah.
And
let me couple that with a question I see,
is Bitcoin really private?
And so let's couple that with the issue
of money laundering or ransom payments,
which happened recently when
the US oil pipeline was shut down.
And in demand by a cyber attack,
and the ransom was paid in Bitcoin.
So money laundering, ransom payments and
privacy, well, it's not private at all.
Everybody can see the blockchain,
everybody has full vision of
Bitcoin on the blockchain.
But of course,
you don't have the name of the person,
like it doesn't say
Darrell Duffie has 212 Bitcoin.
It just gives the ISP, and so
people can track what I'm doing by that.
It turns out that the US authorities are
starting to get pretty good at tracking
payments of Bitcoin on the blockchain.
And they actually tracked down
the ransom payments and told the,
well, basically got back several
million dollars of the ransom.
And more recently, a lot of Bitcoin
was stolen from the blockchain,
and the thieves were forced to give
it back because they were called out.
And everybody knew where those
bitcoins were going in effect, and
were tracking them, so
they basically get most of it back.
So it's not private.
Paper money, if you really want to hide
your wealth is much more effective,
except that you have to then guard
it in a much more expensive way, and
it's hard to move around the world.
>> What would back the US stable coin?
And what is the estimated cost
reduction from the 2% of GDP?
>> Okay, well,
let's talk about the backing,
it's the same backing as paper money.
So when the Central Bank
issues paper money,
there is no backing,
it's just an I owe you.
So it says the Fed owes you if you
have $100 bill, the Fed owes you $100.
So you could use that $100.
If you got enough dollars, you could use
it to buy from the Fed Treasury securities
through your bank or something like that.
But there's nothing in the sense
that there's no money in the, or
there's no gold in a vault or
physical assets backing it.
It's an I owe you.
Just like when you have money in your
bank, it's not, there's no stack of coins
or anything else sitting in the bank
waiting for you to come and collect it.
It's simply an I owe you, and when you
call the I owe you, the bank says, okay,
we'll pay you and
we'll cash in something else to do that.
So almost all money in the world now is
in the form of an I owe you, one way or
another.
And almost none of it has backing.
Many years ago, fiat currencies like
the dollar and most currencies in fact,
had gold backing.
But that was abandoned, the supply of
gold became too limited and in any case,
the price of gold is too
volatile to be a backing.
The monetary authorities are able
to keep the price of fiat currency,
reasonably stable.
US inflation has been between zero and
2% for about three decades.
So it's with some ups and downs.
Right now it's a bit more than two, but
fiat currencies are very stable in price.
So you don't need to worry about
the backing for the dollar.
Maybe if you were in Zimbabwe or
some other country who has a history
of very, very high inflation.
You might be worried that there's nothing
backing your paper money so maybe you
should trade it for something else like
a different fiat currency or gold.
>> Hi, this is Zack from Singapore.
So I want to really ask you the question
about the regulator and the regulation.
Because recently it
sounds like government,
Swiss language launched before and
the Singapore government,
also the Central Bank had just launched
a digital payment token license.
Also tried to address some of the AML and
anti money laundering issue here.
So what's your view on the regulator?
What's the regulator role here for the
regulating all those different currency?
>> The regulator really should be running
the show because money is a public good.
It's like the Internet.
It's like the Internet,
it's like the highway system,
the air traffic control system,
these are all public goods.
They're utilities that we all
depend on and that any one firm or
individual doesn't really internalize
all the benefits of keeping money and
the payments system stable.
And highly efficient.
So the government really or regulators
really have a key role in deciding on
the design of the payment system,
and how to regulate its use.
Now that said,
the private sector such as yourself, Zack,
you're the entrepreneurs that are working
within the rules that the regulator sets.
I know Ravi Menon at
the Monetary Authority of Singapore.
He's an excellent regulator and I'm sure
he and the Monetary Authority of Singapore
are very effective at working
with firms like yours.
Singapore, one of the most advanced
treatments of FinTech payments of
any country in the world.
It's way ahead of many other countries.
As you know, you have your fast payment
system which is very effective.
And Singapore has a cross
border fast payment system now.
And moreover, Singapore is considering
ahead of most countries what, and
carefully what to do about
Central Bank digital currencies.
And I've seen some of their work on that.
So you can be, I think very
confident that your country is
doing a great job from
the regulatory standpoint.
And making sure that citizens
in Singapore have access to
efficient payments that are safe.
>> So my question tags on to
the last month, and that is,
what are your recommendations for
keeping the regulatory bodies
relatively unpoliticized?
because now what we're talking about is
who regulates and what's their agenda.
So, because we're talking
about things that have.
Massive global implications
as opposed to the typical
geographically centered fiat currency.
>> Yeah, Bernard,
I totally agree with your comment.
You want the regulators to be
non-political and also aligned, so
they need to have a plan.
And that plan is first up to Congress,
which authorizes the administration
to design the plan.
And the United States is behind,
and Congress and
the administration have
agreed we are behind.
They're very explicit.
They have said, we should have already
known what to do about stablecoins and
cryptocurrencies.
But now we're catching up,
that's basically what's happening.
And you have a little bit of,
it's not just the regulator in the US,
it's many regulators.
So the Securities and Exchange Commission
under Chair Gary Gensler is taking
a lot of action under the authorities
of the securities regulations.
Other regulators are taking a bit
more time to be thoughtful about it.
The Fed is, in my view, being so
thoughtful that they're
falling behind even further.
And they need to move along.
I've had notes from people in Congress,
I won't name names,
that have suggested that the Fed
should be moving along faster on this.
And Chair Powell of the Fed has said he's
genuinely uncertain whether the US needs
a central bank digital currency.
And as I mentioned,
several governors of the Fed are kind of
pointing different directions on this.
So the Fed needs to move along as well.
But I think the Fed is waiting for
guidance from the administration.
So I think President Biden's
administration will be providing guidance
on this issue in the near future.
And then the Fed will move.
It will release its white paper,
get comments, and decide what to do.
Will they allow stablecoins, don't know.
Will they promote development of CBDC,
don't know.
My suspicion is, though, that they will
try to do better with the bank rail
payment system and
maybe they will make the case.
We don't need all that new stuff.
What we need to do is
improve the old stuff.
Put in fast bank rail payments,
do a better job on
competition with banking,
and let the banks run this.
They have done a reasonable
job on anti-money laundering.
They've done a reasonable job
on protecting your privacy.
In my view, they've done an unreasonably
bad job on competing with each other to
give you good services at low prices, and
to innovate with smarter payment systems.
And as a result, here we are today,
way behind in the United States.
Every economist and every regulator
that I've spoken to agrees that
the United States is further behind than
any other major country in this area.
>> Hi, so it's Mark Louis.
And Professor Duffy,
I will confess this is an area that I'm
still trying to get my head around.
So I may have some fundamental
misunderstandings of how some of
this works.
But to me, a central bank digital currency
is just an electronic form of another fiat
currency, like a paper currency.
And so in my mind, notwithstanding the
fact that there's a lot of design issues
and regulatory issues and
whatnot, it seems to me, and
this is an editorial comment from somebody
that's not very well informed, to be
the natural extension of what the Fed does
in terms of the paper money in the system.
So I find it attractive, or at least
interesting from that perspective.
The issue probably is what it does
to the existing commercial banks,
both in the US and elsewhere.
Because as a consumer or as a businessman,
I could see that if I was able to transact
at the Central Bank, as much fun as
the guys at Chase and Wells Fargo are,
they would become disintermediated
in probably less than ten seconds.
And so I guess the question
that I've got for you, and
I'm not really sure it's
the right question,
is what does this do to the commercial
bank infrastructure, if you will?
What does it do to the profit model of a
commercial bank, to their balance sheets?
And there are other values the commercial
banks are having the economy
in terms of conducting monetary policy,
and multipliers, and
all sorts of other things.
So it seems like I'm fumbling.
But it seems like such a radical
reordering of the financial system,
that I just have trouble
getting my head around it.
Anyway, I'm not sure where
the question is in there, but
just I'd love to hear your comments.
>> Well, Mark, you bet, you've nailed it.
That's the $64 trillion
question that you've nailed.
We have a weak payment
system because banks don't
have incentive to make it better.
And if the alternative is everything
is done at the central bank,
that disrupts the entire banking system.
And so you've got these two extremes, both
of which are not that attractive actually.
Because, I mean, central banks are very
effective at what they do, but they're
not noted for facing every single citizen
in the country with retail services.
And they might mess that up.
They might mess up your data security.
They might have an operational outage and,
whoops, nobody can pay anybody.
So we don't want to go whole hog,
all the way to the extreme.
And if you go the other way,
of course, if you just say,
well, we don't want to do that, we'll
just let the banks continue as they are.
That's also terrible because,
as I mentioned,
we have a decrepit payment system,
if you ask me.
And I think most people
would agree with that.
So what's the happy medium?
The happy medium is either regulate
the banks harder for competition,
allow entry by FinTech firms, or
force banks to compete harder and
open up banking services at lower cost.
Or introduce a central bank digital
currency that's not the extreme version
that I just described.
It's a version in which the banks and
other payment service
providers are facing you.
They are designing the software
that you are using on
your mobile phone up to a uniform
standard of interoperability.
And they are responsible for
monitoring your payments for legality and
protecting your data, just as we
have today in terms of monitoring.
So I would guess that the US
government is going to figure this out.
And they're going to take
one of those two approaches.
A, fix the current bank
rail payment system, or B,
introduced a hybrid system in which
the banks are still running everything but
you're using central bank money.
And going back to your question, Mark,
even that will be disruptive to the banks.
Because if you're using
central bank money a lot,
that means you're not using your
bank deposits to make payments.
Banks will have to go out and
get their funding on the wholesale
funding market to a greater extent.
The cost of their funding will go up,
bank profitability will go down.
That's a commonly agreed thing.
And then we need to think about,
will that affect loan provision?
Will banks then not want
to make as many loans,
because now their deposit
funding is more costly?
And there's a massive debate
going on in that area as well.
Where there are some that say, well,
banks will become less profitable, but
they weren't offering any loans at a loss.
So they're going to continue making the
same loans that they were already making.
And others say, well, you don't get it.
I mean, I'm one of the former camp.
Others will say, you don't get it.
If you cause banks to have to pay more for
deposits and
compete harder,
they'll be more reluctant to make loans.
So that all has to be sorted, and
it's no wonder the Fed is having trouble
Making up its mind but it's going to have
to make up its mind pretty soon because
not only is it neat,
is there a benefit to making a choice.
Everybody now is commenting and the Fed
is under pressure the government and
therefore the administration
is under pressure to
resolve what's the best course to take.
And this is all changed if you
asked someone five years ago and
the government should we introduce a CBDC?
They would say, well, not really,
because everything is there's
nobody really needs that.
Now everybody on the government is saying,
gosh, that's a really tough question.
I don't know but
we should try to solve that right away.
>> Yeah.
Hi, Professor Duffy,
my question follows on Mark's question
a bit of the big picture macro
economic effects of having
a central bank digital currency.
And I'm wondering, from your view,
what are all of the other areas where
having a almost instantaneous transfer
of money is going to be disruptive.
Because for example, in the securities
markets we have T+2 settlement right now.
Lots of security fails and of course that
just moderates the velocity of money
by having this two day settlement inside
of the securities markets that I'm.
And you think about how households have
their paychecks going into the bank, so
then that also mitigates sort of how
fast they can be transferring money.
So what are your views on having
a reasonably constructed central bank
card currency as you had said,
either through banks or directly.
What would macro economists need to factor
in that is a new world in that situation?
>> Well, that's a super good question and
it's another one that's fostered
a huge amount of debate.
So, it sounds like you might have
been working on Wall Street or
you might be working on Wall Street.
>> It's a regulator.
>> Yeah, okay.
Well then you know the famous saying on
Wall Street, that nothing good happens
between the time at which a trade is
made and the time at which it's settled.
In other words, if you can, settle
trades faster because then you're not
exposed to counter party risk and moreover
the money that you have tied up and
the securities that you have tied
up until the settlement is done.
Or trapped or committed and they're in
you want to get those released as soon as
possible so that the system
is more liquid and efficient.
The counter argument to that is first.
Well, if we do instant settlement
using blockchain technology,
which is now possible.
Then everybody that wants to buy
securities will have to have the money
lined up before they make the trade
because it's kind of settled instantly so
you got to be ready.
And the other concern is that
you want to make sure that
the block chain architecture is really,
really solid.
And I suspect that problem can be
circumvented last March as since your
insecurities that settlement
failures soared in just three weeks.
Last March three weeks ago,
$1.5 trillion of Treasury
securities transactions were not
settled on time they failed.
And that was a really a light bulb went
off in Washington and said we gotta do
something about the settlement
system in our securities markets.
And I've been advocating
first central clearing so
that you're not depending on your
counterparty directly you have
a clearinghouse that
guarantees the payments.
And then investigating blockchain
settlement that would allow faster
settlement and I've been working or
writing a paper with
digital asset holding.
Which is a blockchain settlement company,
that a wall street firm,
a FinTech startup, that's doing
wholesale security settlement.
And you can find the paper
on my website and Stevie DC,
if it's done in a blockchain would
accelerate that because it would make it
possible to do instant
settlement on the blockchain.
If you securitize, if you tokenize,
both the securities and the money,
and you could do it with CBDC or you
could do it with a private stable coin.
Doesn't have to be retail.
It could be just wholesale and a lot
of countries are doing just wholesale.
Switzerland, Canada, Singapore,
a number of countries
are exploring just wholesale
CBDCs because of this issue,
although there's no
major breakthroughs yet.
>> Yeah, nice to see you again.
>> Yes, I remember you from my class.
Good to see you.
>> Good to see yeah.
Yeah, I was working for
under the current season soon CBC
infrastructure for a while now.
So what I see from my point of view
of like from like from crypto wall so
right now there is a merge like
kind of meta banking thing.
It's when the people earn money and
receive the money in their crypto
space and what do you think like.
So this means that there
will be opportunity for
something like financial institution that
works not under one jurisdiction but
kind of middle layer and
am baffled as he does dictions.
And what do you think like in
different countries, they got their
governments they will fight it, they will
adopt it, they will kind of plug in.
Or maybe they will create their own
kind of metal financial institution.
So what's the plan?
>> Well, China is going to block it.
The United States is still
deciding what to do.
For those of you that
are not following this,
what Igor is talking about is
called DeFi decentralized finance.
And almost everything that you
can do in traditional finance,
which is called TradFi now.
You can also do in
the cryptocurrency space using
blockchain based system so
you can borrow money.
You can invest in cryptocurrencies
you can make payments.
You can sign derivative securities
options, forwards futures,
all kinds of basically all the major
things that are happening in
traditional securities markets
like Christina was talking about.
And money and banking you can
now do in the crypto space.
Recently, the Securities and Exchange
Commission of the United States threatened
to sue Coinbase over its proposed lending
of cryptocurrencies on its service and.
Coinbase initially bridled up the idea
that what they were doing was subject
to SEC regulation but generally speaking,
it's not a good idea to go up against
a the securities in exchange commission.
And Coinbase is back down and
they're going to comply they're not
going to release their lending
a cryptocurrency lending program.
But off the as Igor suggested globally,
most of these activities
are not regulated.
And they're going to be brought
into regulation country by country.
And my suspicion is that
the United States will say something like
the following, okay?
You can do all this stuff because we
already let banks and securities firms and
others do it but you have to
meet exactly the same standards.
So you have to have full compliance,
you have to do full anti money laundering.
You have to do full auditing of
all of your customer accounts for
what Christina may know
is a 15C 3 requirement so
that you're protecting your
customer account money.
You have to do everything the whole
nine yards of regulation for banking and
securities.
And there may be additional regulations
laid on top of that, that will mitigate
some of the concerns associated
with anonymity or illegal payments.
So I would anticipate Igor,
if you have friends that are doing this,
that they'll be able to continue to do it.
But they're going to be required
in the United States and
in some of the countries to meet the whole
gamut of very, very rigorous regulation.
Right now, if you ask stablecoin
developers like dm what they most want,
they most want to know what
are the regulations going to be?
They say fine, bring it on but tell us
what the regulations are going to be.
And then we can make our business plans
and get money and raise capital and
innovate.
But until we know exactly what
the regulatory landscape will look like,
it's very difficult for
us to move forward.
And that's why the United States needs
to move on this pretty quickly and
the administration the regulators
are moving and they're meeting.
It's a hot item in Washington,
everybody that I know and
we're all my contacts and
agencies telling me that it's a very hot
issue in Washington right now
partly brought on by China.
United States does not
want to get left behind.
I think it's enough I forget about China.
That's important, but
it's enough just to address the US
payment system to get this right.
Thank you for
the very perceptive questions.
All the questions that you
asked were fabulous, and
I'll go through the chat
if you'll send it to me.
>> Absolutely.
Thank you to everybody for
joining us today and
I hope you enjoy the rest of reunion and
virtual alumni week.
Thanks.